- En fait, ça s'appelle
"Un ho
- La mer est omniprésente
dans leséoéoéos, les photos
de ce conteur et musicien
chilien établi en France très e.
ENRIQUE RAMIREZ, artiste
- Cette personne-là,
elle s'attache à cette voile
à quelque chose pour survivre.
- - - Une pièce entière est occe
par un triptyque évoquant
la dictatureque personne ne veu.
- L'exposition s'appelle
"Los durmientes", "Le dormeur".
C'est un grand triptyque,ueueuee
j'ai faite en 2014, qui parle
donc les gens qui étaient lancés
de Pinochet, des opposants
politiques qui n'ont jamais
une pièce qui parle directement
de la dictature et de
tous les problèmes autour
de la disparition des gens. e ee
voile inversée, le nord au sud.
Elle évoque le voyage
d'indigènes mexicains
espagnols de l'Amérique.
- C'est un pmemememe
une cartographie poétique
d'un voyage, de ce voyage.
migrants, appelé la Jungle,
dans le nord de la France,
face à l'Angleterre, s'attachent
pudiquement, sans personnage.
LOUISE DErererererectrice
Galerie de l'UQAM
- Enrique Ramirez, c'esti i i ic
beaucoup d'humanité de sujets
qu'on place plutôt facilement
sous l'angle du politique, mais
son rapport au texte, c'est
i i i i i un compositeur de mus,
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille
les images ade soin, beaucoup d,
c'est un langage qui est tr
authentique et qui passe,
qui passe auprès des gens.
On reçoit ses oeuvres avec
une forme d'empathie, une  notr.
- Sa deuxième présence à
un clin d'oeil de la Galerie
de l'UQAM à tous les Chiliens
qui ont choisi le Québec
sous la dictature.
Jean-Michel Lep
Radio-Canada, Montréa